just be yourself you can't be nobody
else because you're always gonna be
second if you're trying to be somebody
else yeah you never be the best you can
possibly be for you and you you know you
know you're doing yourself injustice
because you know you never going to be
the best you can be because you're
trying to be somebody else I'm Julio
Jones with Atlanta Falcons
I played wide receiver I'm 28 years old
I started investing in the mother
Georgia project at first it started off
as a small project for me while family
entertainment center at first there are
all the guys we always had to drive like
45 minutes to an hour all the way
downtown to do something especially guys
with kids or the guys on the team with
kids wise things like that I'm just
having something up there for us all to
go to and not be disturbed and just have
fun working with one of my partner's
jungling things like that just like hey
we can do it bigger we can do it better
you know that's where more real estate
come in apartments condos things like
that and also the retail and also like I
said the family entertainment center
just have them a Center where they can
go they can also study and also just
work on whatever sport they want to do
you have done with that it's worth
noting really changed for me you know I
knew where I was at you know once I got
drafted I just did everything I wanted
to do for my mom's you know like early
write get her house get her car quit her
job things like that because she did so
much for me
early on taking care of me and showing
me unconditional love so I just love
just being able to give and just take
care of the people I care about who care
about me
you got to have that drive that ambition
where and you got to be self-motivated
we notice a lot of things you're doing
in life people not going to support you
because they don't have the same vision
around you just got to make people
believe I'm sorry
like I was saying like about my projects
like I don't like to talk about it and
things like that like I would like to
show you
[Music]